Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kunters and we are continuing our
videos on functional genetics, looking at your genetics for issues and today we're going to talk
about oxalate issues or oxalic acid issues. This is a common problem that is hidden and many times
unrecognized with people. Oxalates are a chemical that's founded a lot of really good foods.
So things that you maybe eat if you've changed your diet and are trying to eat well,
oxalates are in a lot of great things. It's actually a protective measure
by the plant to keep animals from eating it. Oxalates can be toxic to different animals
and like rhubarb, for instance, what it's in the spring there's less oxalates in the rhubarb
has the rhubarb ages through late summer. There's a greater amount of oxalates in rhubarb
and it can cause problems with some people as we're going to see especially if they have some genetic
defects that predispose them to different oxalate issues. People with oxalate problems,
like I said many times it's masked, they think it's something else. Oxalate problems,
primarily are known for stone formation, kidney stones, and gallstones, and liver stones,
and bile duct stones, and things like that. But some hidden things are like
joint problems, even rheumatoid arthritis and osteoarthritis issues,
greater ability to form calcium spurs, so spur-forming people. Even it's been
tied to a glossy spondylitis problems, arthritis in the spine, as well as muscle issues,
achy, painful muscles. Typically people that are diagnosed with fibrobiologist should really look
at their genes and see if it's tied to oxalate issues. So anybody with achy, painful muscles,
sore joints should really look at if they have oxalate issues and we're going to look at that.
Dietary oxalates really are supposed to be converted and excreted. So we really shouldn't
be absorbing a lot of oxalates from our food. That is, we'll see it's the genetic defects that
actually decrease this conversion and increase the absorption of oxalates from our food,
and so people that have these G defects are more prone to having high serum plasma
oxalate levels, and that as it's excreted through different organs, calcium binds to it,
and we end up forming the calcium oxalate crystals, stone formation. So also different defects
cause glycodates in the body to be converted to oxalates and you increase the creation of oxalates
in your own body, and it really has very little to do with dietary oxalates. So just stay it away from
dietary or foods that have high oxalates is not always the solution for people.
Benefactor, you look at the listed, you can search a list on Google of foods that have
high oxalates, it's many things that are very good for you that you really want to be eating.
So you want to address the reason why always and that's what we're going to talk about.
There's really so high oxalate levels in your body is called hyper-oxaluria.
It really means a high amount of oxalates in your urine, but we're not just talking about the urine
is further research has indicated, this is an older name, but it has stuck. It has to do with plasma
level of oxalates as well. It's separated at two different forms, primary hyper-oxaluria,
and secondary primary has to do with it's from a genetic defect. We're going to talk about the
three different types of primary hyper-oxaluria, and secondary has to do nothing to do with the genes,
but has to do with gut issues, leaky gut yeast, candida, overgrowth, fungus issues, dysbiosis,
from all sorts of reasons having gut issues so that you're just absorbing a lot of oxalates
through the gut has nothing to do with genetics, but just has to do with it's just passing through the
gut, lighting from a damaged gut, so then you end up with increased oxalates in your body that way.
So we'll look at both of these and some solutions for both of these as we go through this presentation.
These are really the genes that we're looking at when we look at primary hyper-oxaluria,
and we're going to go through these one by one. The SPP1 genes, the effects of these genes,
and remember if you've got a blank after the gene that means you have no defect, a one means you have
a single allele defect, and a two means you have a homogenous defect or a double allele defect,
which means you have even a worse problem with that gene. So the SPP1 genes, it's typically that
first one on top there, this chart right here, this is going to be a type of primary type one,
and this is going to be typically a stone-former person here as well, but you're going to take all
these genes in conjunction. The AG-X-T gene is typically what you're going to read about with primary
hyper-oxaluria type one. This gene is found in the peroxisomes in the liver, and its purpose is to
make an enzyme to help remove toxins as well as to help dissolve fats. So defects in this gene can
lead to fatty liver, defects in this gene can lead to decreased ability to get rid of toxins,
other toxins in your body, and certainly can lead to increase oxalates in your body. Also,
defects inhibit the conversion of glycoxalate to glycine. And glycine is essential if you remember,
if you watch any of my videos on the glutathione pathway. Glycine is essential for making glutathione.
Defects in this gene can be a precursor to glutathione issues, and glutathione is your
main intracellular antioxidant, so that can lead to cancer issues and other cell dysfunction issues,
too. This gene is very B-sex-dependent, and people deficient in B-sex with a gene defect here
can even have worse problems. You're going to see in one of the solutions that I'm going to offer
as a product that increases B-6 load. The type 2 has to do with this GRHPR gene. This makes a
specific enzyme that if you have defects in it, you reduce the excretion of ingested oxalates. So
you are going to increase the absorption of oxalates, especially if you have any twos in any of
these genes. So any double allele defects in any of the GRH genes, you are going to increase
absorption of ingested. So dietary oxalates, you are just going to quite easily absorb those,
and this is a major cause of stone formation here. This is also tied to low sulfur issues, and this
will, the more oxalates, you absorb, it has an inverse proportion to sulfur and B-6, so it's
going to lower B-6 levels and affect that other gene as well. So for this patient right here,
this sample patient having a double allele defect on the first GRHPR gene definitely would be
an order to do some things to intervene with that. The type 3 primary is this HOGA1 gene. This
person has several single allele defects in this gene. I don't know if they had no stone formation
that I would do any nutritional intervention, but maybe some dietary intervention. They are going to
overproduce oxalates. It will inhibit excretion and it will increase plasma oxalate levels. So
greater chance for not just kidney stone issues, but joint issues, fiber biology issues because
you will have oxalate crystals in the muscles as well. Secondary hyperoxyluria, you are dealing
with leaky gut issues. There are genetic components to that, but we are not talking about the specific
oxalate genes. We are talking about the genetic components that lead to leaky gut, like FUT2 gene
defects. Also, there is evidence that decreased autophagy increases oxalate issues, so the ULK,
the ATG genes, and the FIP genes. These are also out of your report that we go over. We will show a
decrease in autophagy. So remember, autophagy is getting rid of dead tissues, getting rid of dead cells,
your body is basically garbage system to get rid of these things, and a decreased function in any of
these genes are going to lead to rises in oxalate levels. Now, how do you know if you have a rise in
oxalate levels, so that's a good question. If you have any history of kidney stones or any family
history of kidney stones and gallstones and liver stones and such, you already should have a red
flag go up in your head, because that's your number one pointer. You could say, well, no, I don't have
any history of that, but you may have looked back at these genes as we go through your genetic profile,
and you have a lot of genetic defects in these genes, but you have no history of that. So there are
other ways to measure your current oxalic acid load. Great Pleiades lab has a organic acid test that
measures that organic, that oxalic load. So if you know if you have either one of 19-20 along with 21
high, like this person does, they're higher on the glyceric acid and higher on the oxalic acid,
they definitely have some primary hyperoxyluria going on. So this is one way to measure with a lab test,
with okay, I did my genes, and I do have some genetic defects. Maybe they're not horrific, and I don't
have any really family history that I know of, of kidney stones, or joint issues, or fibromyalgia
issues, but I do want to look at my levels, well, then we can run this lab, and that could give us those
levels. So what do you do about it? Are we to stay away from those foods that you saw that list? Well,
we could certainly Google different foods and try to decrease our load of oxalates, and as I've
shared in the past, one of the things that we've done in the past before, some new products came out
is simply giving magnesium citrate, and calcium citrate, or magnesium orotate, that helps find the
oxalates in the gut, and helps prevent their absorption, though it's not perfect, can be very beneficial.
Well, just this last month, methylgenetic nutrition came out with an oxalate scavenger product that has
not only the magnesium and calcium in there, but it has the B6 in the form of P5P, which is a great
form of B6, because remember I said B6 will be diminished with oxalate problems. So definitely with
primary hyperoxyluria, that means coming from your genes. So not solely from a leaky gut, but really
you have the gene defects that are causing the increase oxalic acid problems or increase risk for
oxalate issues. This would be the product to use. It has a little vitamin D, vitamin K2 in it,
the B6 as I stated in the calcium and magnesium, plus a spore-based probiotic, which is really helpful
for people with oxalate issues. So this is a great product that maybe we want to go up kind of slow,
start at one or two a day, and slowly tie trade up to four a day, let's list it on this label,
and that could really make a difference with people. People can see decreases in their
fibromyalgia symptoms. They can see decreases in their pain and their joint pain issues. They
certainly see a decrease risk in stone formation, and if you've ever had kidney stones, you don't
want to have them again. That's one of the most painful things to have. So this is a great product
for that. If you have secondary problems, meaning I don't have the genetic issues,
but I have a lot of the symptoms that you're talking about, and I definitely have leaky gut issues,
and we measure whether or not we do, but if we measured the oxalate issues with the
organic acid tested, you had high oxalates with no genetic issues, then we treat for secondary
hyperoxyloriate, and then we'd use this product, the oxalate balancer. So oxalate balancer
still has some of the P5, P, and B6 in it. Still has the calcium magnesium, a little bit of zinc,
but it has some other herbs to help heal the gut, help balance the dysbiosis problem, and help
decrease any fungus or Candida issues. That may be a primary cause of the gut imbalance,
and increase absorption. This you'd start at about one or two a day and try trade up to three or
a day. This is another really great product that we're excited to have. Again, if we have not read
your genes, or if you have questions about your genes, and you are a patient, feel free to call,
and we could go over these. We maybe, we didn't cover these with yours because we were concerned more,
with other things prior to this, since these are necessarily cancer function genes.
Make sure you call, schedule a time to go over those. If you're watching this video and you're not
a patient, we do have some plans that offer genetic workups, so just contact our office, our website
right there, and we'll get in touch soon. All right, thank you very much.